an einer stark befahrenen kreuzung in
münchen schwabing steht er der
denkmalgeschützte hochbunker aus der
nazizeit 1953 gebaut sollte er gut 700
menschen bei bombenangriffen schutz
bieten
heute ist er einer der ungewöhnlichsten
wohnhaus jürgen münchen
hallo mein name ist davon höglmeier
zeigt den letzten rang ab stefan huegel
meyer wohnt ganz oben im bunker über
drei etagen und rund vier quadratmeter
erstreckt sich die wohnung des
immobilienentwicklers der
einrichtungsstil nimmt anleihen aus
vielen epochen die harten formen des
bunkers kontrastieren mit verspielten
elementen
[Musik]
stefan huegel meyer hat die originale
struktur des gebäudes an vielen stellen
bewusst offen gelegt auch mal gegangen
hat was vom sehr bedrückend zwei meter
dicke wände und 0 außenraum bezug und
das eben über alle stockwerke über
liegenden stockwerke und das natürlich
so nicht kennt warum sonst im gebäude
rein geht irgendwann hat man dann mal
licht luft ausblick um diesen bezug zur
außenwelt zu schaffen ließ er in jede
wand ein fenster schneiden vier fenster
groß stockwerk als stefan huegel neueres
gebäude 2010 erwarb war der bunker noch
so aus 15 arbeiter waren fast sieben
monate damit beschäftigt die öffnungen
in den zwei meter dicken witterung zu
schneiden
2000 tonnen beton haben wir hier raus
genommen
also fasst diese öffnungen die wir
geschaffen haben insgesamt ungefähr das
gewicht von 2000 pkw und das war
durchaus eine bauliche herausforderung
aber ich glaube es war nicht nur die
bauliche herausforderungen sondern auch
überhaupt thema wie man sich dem wert an
gebäude aus der nazi zeit um zu nutzen
und eben dann auch bewohnbar zu machen
für geschichte ein bezug herzustellen
die geschichte nicht zu verwischen also
lesbar zu lassen spuren sichtbar zu
lassen und trotzdem auch natürlich
wohnlichkeit herzustellen dass es
funktioniert
eine treppe führt in die neu gebaute
oberste etage auch für das penthouse
muss für ein loch in den meter dickem
beton beschnitten werden dort sind wir
dann final über den bunker hat man
gigantischen ausblick hier sind erstmal
der essplatz und weiteren ist das
wohnzimmer im wahrsten sinne des wortes
lichtdurchflutet ist man hat hier den
nordfriedhof mit einem meer von bäumen
der mit dem englischen garten verspielt
unter schock
[Musik]
die dachterrasse des hauses bietet einen
360 grad blick auf münchen um seinen
bayerischen wurzeln treu zu bleiben gibt
es bei stefan bögl weiher sogar eine
outdoor stube aus zu bereuen
so kann man wind und sonne geschützt
draußen
[Musik]
stefan huegel meyer hat mit seiner firma
für rund fünf millionen euro den bunker
in ein hochmodernes gebäude verwandelt
in den 26 meter hohen turm gibt es nicht
nur weitere wohnungen und büros sondern
auch eine galerie namens wmr bunker hier
finden regelmäßig ausstellungen mit
schwerpunkt kunst und architektur stadt
öffentlich zugänglich und kostenlos
eine echte herzensangelegenheit von
stefan huegel meyer der bunker ist stand
hier jahrzehntelang im stadtraum ganz
stark wahrnehmbar als schreckgespenst
und ja ich finde eben ganz wichtig dass
die bevölkerung des weiteren erfahren
kann und eben jetzt auch leben kann wie
das bei gebäude befriedet wurde
wohnen im hochbunker mit viel liebe und
engagement wurde aus einem münchen
wertschöpfungs ein vorzeigeobjekt
memmingen